so we have what three and a half million
registered voters in new york
um of like probably what four to five
million
people are eligible to vote in the city
of any million population like
you know something around there um and
you only get
800 000 or so to actually vote is it
that they don't care they don't know to
care
they don't they're distracted by other
things is it the society of scarcity
mindset of scarcity you talk about where
people are too busy trying to pay rent
to care about
voting or community involvement like why
do we not give
a [ __ ] having the ability to care about
politics is something of a luxury good
truly
uh you know like you you you do have
other basic needs to attend to they're
busy paying the bills they're you know
like that they're busy
um scrambling to take care of their kids
uh in particular ways uh i i
you know and i and i think it's
sometimes tough
to care because a lot of times your
candidate doesn't win
[Music]
um
[Music]
on today's episode of yang speaks andrew
and myself zach grauman your co-host we
sit down and we talk about
how we lost the new york city mayor's
race guys it's the closest thing we'll
get to kind of a postmortem from andrew
yang for
a while we also talk about what was
going through his head as he was running
and where this movement goes it's a
fascinating episode is a good debrief of
the six month
roller coaster he was just on you're not
going to want to miss it
tune in to yank speaks talking about the
new york city mayor's race
recap right now
[Music]
[Applause]
hello everyone welcome back to yang
speaks where
i am going to be doing a debrief
with zach oh the post mortem the post
mortem
i'm gonna ask what everybody's thinking
right now how you feeling thank you
i'm doing all right really uh you know
i'm still have a bit of smoke coming off
the top of my head
a lot of emotion um you know uh
like a set of results that didn't go our
way and so there there's been a lot of
talks and phone calls and uh things like
that but generally speaking
i'm doing all right you know it's like
you you look up and you realize that
uh it's summer which i hadn't really
realized until
very recently
you know days you don't know what day of
the week it is yeah i mean
yeah like i i i have to remind my
uh my kids what daddy looks like because
uh you know i've been out of pocket a
lot but
the things are good on that side i feel
i feel like i need some exercise and
some uh
some healthy days um but generally i'm
doing well
i'm pretty positive
uh you know despite the fact that this
race didn't go our way for people who
are concerned about me
thank you love you uh but uh i'm i'm
fine
and uh still pumped up in my own way
what's monday morning quarterback like
where's your head at as you look
back what's on your mind and you want to
share i do want to take a moment to
look at the results because some people
are obviously very interested based on
the right choice voting
uh i believe that eric adams is going to
win based on the numbers
i'll give you an example of a woman in
the bronx who
said to me i voted for you and then to
prove it she took out her worksheet
that showed who she was going to be
voting for
um and it had my name number one which i
appreciated and then
maya wiley number two uh and then eric
adams number three
um and so most people would look at it
and say well if someone chose me
uh then maybe they wouldn't choose eric
or someone chose maya they wouldn't
choose eric but
um but all three of us were the top
three choices on her ballot
and i think that's going to be very
normal i think that they're going to be
people
who uh have different candidates in
different orders
such that it's almost mathematically
impossible for eric adams not to
win based upon the the lead that he has
so i want to put that out there to folks
and
it's one reason why uh looking at the
numbers
uh you know we decided not to
uh say that you know we thought we had a
path because based on the numbers we
didn't think we had a path
based on the numbers it seemed like
a near certainty that eric adams will be
the democratic nominee
so just want to put that out there for
folks who are
looking at the numbers and obviously
it's a first ranked choice voting
election so
like you would want to wait and see and
like no one
knows precisely what's going to happen
but based on everything i've seen
uh i i think it's a near certainty that
eric wins
yeah there was in all of the ranked
choice voting polls that were done
um when they when they actually there's
a lot of polls that were done but not
all of them actually ran all it's called
seven rounds of
uh ranked choice voting no one ever came
back
from much of a deficit um i think the
highest deficit i saw like someone go
from second to first or first down
second um was i think four points three
points
um but no one had come close to
overcoming a nine and a half point lead
which is what eric has over maya wiley
um and uh 20 herb you know
well over 10 point lead over over
catholic garcia so
i agree with you i think that number's
pretty obvious i mean it's possible but
probably not i don't think so not an
absolute certainty but
it's it it's very very very likely when
we started running
everyone was indoors it was coved the
fact that i was even
interacting with people physically
outside was remarkable
and i think there were some people even
that had an issue with it
though everyone followed our lead
pretty quickly but the primary issue in
the campaign
went from reopening and coveting the
economy and jobs
to crime and security
uh sometime around the same time frame
really when everyone started coming
outside again
in a crime race um it's a hierarchy of
needs right
like crime trumps the economy and safety
trumps the economy in many ways
um and
[Music]
the problem there for us i thought i
don't know you thought but the
government experience um tends to be
more appealing
when you're talking about safety um like
the outsider
new breath of fresh air is less
appealing when people are getting shot
on the street and stabbed on the street
and don't feel safe in the subways i
don't know what you thought but that was
what i felt when
you know when we prep for debates or
when you're out in the street yeah i
think that was certainly one aspect of
it and there were some
tensions uh within the team where people
would say well you can't out cop the
cop uh what was one thing i heard any
number of times
and for me both common sense and the
numbers indicated that crime
was going to be the number one issue and
so
i tried to in some ways
make as strong a case on public safety
as
any other candidate and we wound up
getting some incredibly powerful
endorsements
in that realm so thank you to the
firefighters
and the police captains for believing
in me as a right person
uh to try and deliver public safety but
i do think that
common sense was that if you have crime
as the number one issue then the person
who uh
was a police officer has has like a
massive
edge um at least in terms of public
perception
and there were people on the team even
who said to me in the
march time frame said like if this race
is about the economy you win if this
race is about crime then
eric wins that's not seemed awfully
fatalistic at the time
but by the time the actual voting rolled
around i think
public safety and crime was the number
one issue for 71 percent of voters and
there was a very steep drop off after
that
yep i remember a conversation you had
i'm going to over over simplify
as i would retell it but it was um
you're like hey zach i
uh we need to rework my stump speech a
bit and i was like what's wrong with
your stunt sheets like
you know you know you're the cash leaf
guy like that's the main message like
we're hammering home like i know it gets
boring but let's stick with the message
and you were like
be crime's up and when i go to speaking
with people on the street
or new supporters or donors or whoever
you're talking to he's like i feel like
i'm not talking about the elephant in
the room if i'm not talking about crime
um i remember you saying that and i
think you're right obviously
you're right the numbers here my
question is like
one of the things every politician i
think struggles with
um and we struggle with of course is
like
there's not a lot of room for nuance um
when you're running for office you're
either like you're tough on crime or
you're not or you're defund the police
or not wherever you want to go
um we had like always
talk about the nuance like when we do
long form where like we need to be safe
safe and we can have a just police
department like thoughts on
the lack of nuance when you're running
but the nuance in your own mind was
um affecting you or or anything you were
thinking there
you know i think that um given who i am
in my profile
um like i needed to hit one clear
message um
and try and have it come through in a
way that maybe some other candidates
could uh naturally get away with like uh
you know more nuance or people would
naturally like would
uh take that that same message
differently so i
if you look at it uh i think that there
were a few things that
uh changed for us number one was
it became the public safety and crime
election
and i talked to someone in atlanta
yesterday and he said the same thing's
happening in atlanta
that like in other parts of the country
where crime is surging as people are
outside
and there's a lot of energy
and it's defining apparently elections
all over
the country where uh so it's not just
you new york but it definitely is very
very front and center here in new york
i think the the other thing that and you
don't wanna to
uh be someone who uh just
bemoans coverage uh but i i think
objectively with a very very hostile
media environment
working against us from day one
manufactured controversies where you're
looking at it saying like what is going
on
there were a lot of folks that said that
to me even people that didn't support me
would say to me like what is going on
with the new york times in particular
the new york times even acknowledged
like we we can't stop
uh talking about angel we can't stop
writing andre yang yes
as the name and article and most of the
coverage was negative um
and then the explanation for it was like
well you're the frontrunner
um and then there was a point when maybe
uh eric was a front-runner
um and that there wasn't the same level
of scrutiny despite having
like a lot more to work with so much
more to work with
but yeah three corruption investigations
and it left me in like a very strange
place where i felt like okay i guess i
have to take it on then
i felt myself like i was in a position
where i i had to
somehow call out problems with
uh with eric because it didn't feel like
the media was going to do it
uh and that was unfortunate and then
even then when i did that that people
would be like what happened to
you know like nice guy like agreeable
uh andrew yang like now he's being so
negative and then you're looking to be
like well
you know i'm kind of doing your job over
here
and so one of the most frustrating
things really was the entire
where does eric adams live thing where
you know news came out that well maybe
he doesn't live
uh in brooklyn maybe he spends most of
his time in new jersey
and then his response was to give people
a tour of a basement
uh and uh i talked to a reporter who was
on that tour
and the reporter said no one actually
thinks he lives in that basement
like having having been on that physical
tour he was like
i do not think that he lives there but
then
after that nothing like the story just
uh goes away
um and then you were looking at it being
like okay so let me get this straight
like we we're not sure
where he lives and he showed you an
apartment that you don't think he lives
in
uh but you know there's nothing else to
be said here
you know i imagine myself in a similar
position where like if it had come out
that
you know like i lived somewhere else and
i gave someone a tour of a place that i
didn't live in like
i do not think that would have been the
end of it it would have been fun page
for days man
yeah they just would have gone on and on
and on um
and so uh even something as basic as the
fact that
you know in in multiple uh interviews he
said that he can't live without a bubble
bath
and the basement that he gave people a
tour of didn't have a bathtub
um and you know it doesn't take like a
detective to say like hey
you know maybe there's an inconsistency
there
but once again it fell to me to point
out what seemed like there was obvious
inconsistency
um and then and then it like you know it
just put me in a spot where
i felt like like i wasn't making a
positive case
and i've had multiple people uh say to
me even who work in the media
who said who would say like yes like
that the coverage was
not uh terribly balanced
uh or fair uh and i
i think that you know some of it you
could say well you know
like it's the front runner treatment but
some of it seemed
uh beyond that people were more
comfortable with
an insider with problems than someone
new to the system
yeah we had built up a lot of goodwill
we you had built up a lot of goodwill
with
people who watch cnn who correlates very
highly with people who read the new york
times
um and that was a strong base in early
polls and that had
basically evaporated because of all the
pieces against you in the new york times
over the past five months
you could list them off you had a piece
on you saying i love the gay community
you had a piece on
giving your dog away they thought you
didn't understand the subway system
which was bs your favorite subway stop
you said it's time square which is right
next to you like that's where you live
it's your stop they were just like silly
pieces
over and over um i thought the piece
they wrote on venture for america
um not being legit was fundamentally
ridiculous um you built that from
scratch from nothing to a six million
dollar organization
it worked everywhere like trying to take
that away from you is fundamentally
[ __ ] up box had it at 4 000 jobs like
a couple days ago and then they came up
with like a
much smaller number because they cherry
picked one narrow stem and they put it
in the headline they put he promised
hundred thousand jobs and he created 150
which is [ __ ] um and if you had
tried
who cares like you know what i'm saying
if your goal is to set that many you
built an entity to grow towards that
direction and never got there
that's also shouldn't be something to
scoff at um
or ridicule it's just critics it threw
under the bus the work of
dozens hundreds thousands of people yes
people you know like
who've done really awesome uh
remarkable things um and because of a
political agenda they just decided to
treat that very very unfairly uh it
so that one i think was among the worst
of it
i had a number of friends say to me it's
like look after this like i
can't actually believe in the new york
times because i know you
i know your work and then i see this
other stuff and i don't even recognize
it
uh where i had people say to me that
they were
watching the mayoral debates and then
they were watching the
coverage in real time and saying like
that the coverage uh is
covering something completely unlike
what they're actually watching with
their own eyes
um so that there was like a real
distortion effect
i felt like i was operating like a world
of fun house mirrors a lot of the time
um it was it was not a good feeling i
had
a number of people say that they got
phone calls
asking them like negative leading
questions and then when
they just said positive things the
reporter would just lose interest and
then like
they're writing they're writing a
narrative right they're they're they
have their narrative they're gonna
pick and choose what fits the narrative
but what was interesting is that you
know like
i hoped that the goodwill
uh i had among uh
voters and and uh readers was high
enough where
they would be able to uh see through
some of this and
it was for a while like it was for a
period of
i don't know three months for the new
york times attacked you
right out the gate right so it probably
lasted three four months yeah
yeah and and so like that that was my
hope
uh during the time um but it was tough
because there weren't that many ways to
communicate
especially when we were all indoors uh
you know like you could do some things
via
um social media um but like
the the the funhouse mirror thing like
was very dispiriting and it felt
very clear and real and then the third
thing is that the
makeup of the new york city special
interest uh
voting groups where i spent a lot of
time courting
different groups different unions um and
would lose out virtually all the time i
i'd get calls sometimes from leaders
saying like hey
really like you uh you know like you you
did a great job
talking to us our members but we're
going with
uh this other candidate uh because of
various relationships that we we've
built up with him over time
and so the the big winners of that were
eric adams uh to a lesser extent scott
stringer uh scott stringer got the
teachers unions
we got um down the stretch very late uh
the firefighters and the police captains
which
um don't represent enormous democratic
voting blocs uh that you know they're
they're very very powerful
symbolically uh but the city employees
as another union
um you know that that represents a lot
of uh voters
like that there were a lot of uh
a lot of blocks uh of voters
uh that we spent a significant amount of
time
um trying to court and would
lose out um you know nine times out of
ten or or even
more uh i think that that's something
that
looking at it now uh it makes sense like
you wouldn't expect
um the union that represents tens of
thousands of employees necessarily to
get on board with that person who's new
but i think that narrative also played
out in in different ways
a supporter of mine said to me said that
like all the institutions were out to
to defeat you like essentially from day
one
um and uh you know that applied to
various interest groups as well
but i also think that affected
you the team also like these things
don't happen in vacuum they happen and
they affect how we
how we act um did you ever feel like
um you couldn't be as authentic as you
wanted to be
did you feel like you had to give a
political line more than you wanted to
be did you feel like um
because of the fun house mirrors or
whatever you're talking about did you
feel like you couldn't be
you well certainly it's tough when
if you say something that seems
innocuous like you don't include the
fact that you're transferring off the
subway line and then it becomes a thing
like you said like you live next to a
subway station someone asked your
favorite subway station and you say it
and then like that that becomes a thing
um so it it certainly makes you think
like huh uh
you know um you asked me like uh an
innocuous seeming question
i give like a fairly natural answer and
then that that kind of spirals into
something
and um there was a very consistent
dynamic
with journalists in particular where
when they were interviewing me there
there was like uh
like trying to like you know play gotcha
and then um all the time they were
trying to ask me whether it's like
uh you know like do do you think
differently about this do you like uh do
you
apologize for this and then if you
say for a moment that you uh
either think differently or apologize
about something then it becomes a story
that's why they're asking
they're just looking for fuel and then
you you want to deny them that fuel
uh but then you wind up being much more
on guard
i had dozens of people over the course
of the campaign
uh try to record what they thought of as
like an embarrassing
interaction where they would have like
you know they'd take out their
smartphone and
like you know try and catch me
or ask which which you know makes you
naturally just feel like okay like you
know and obviously most people are
lovely and most people just want to talk
to you
um and uh take a selfie and then you
know every once in a while someone
uh will try to have what they consider a
viral moment and so it does
change your behavior for sure
this episode of yank speaks is sponsored
by better help
i cannot recommend to you enough how
important mental health is
and how much i love better help i do a
secure conversation
with a counselor once a week
every time i talk to her feels like i'm
letting off steam and it's amazing and
it helps me prepare for the rest of the
week
helps me talk about the things that i
may be bottled up throughout the week
um where it's good to get it out and
it's so easy to use
it's fantastic guys it's time for you to
start taking control of your own mental
health
and stop letting things interfere with
your happiness
and you can start communicating in under
48 hours whether it's about depression
stress anxiety relationships
anger family conflicts grief you name it
it's convenient affordable and
professional so
start living a happier life today as a
listener of yank speaks you're going to
get 10
off your first month by visiting our
sponsor at betterhelp.com so join over
one million people have taken charge of
their mental health
again that's betterhelp hglp.com
yang
[Applause]
so one of the big variables uh was going
to be who voted
and uh what the make up what the nature
of the electorate is going to be
and historically you had something like
seven to eight hundred thousand people
vote in these kinds of races
and the question was whether turnout
goes up because the city's in a very
tough spot
and this was an historic election and
uh turnout did not go up to the point
that to the
uh point that you might have hoped uh i
think right now how many votes have been
kassack
seven almost eight hundred thousand just
a seven
ninety nine eight twenty seven so you
might have something like 900 000 votes
um so that's not that different from the
800 000
in the last uh race
um so it's uh it's an uptick to be sure
it's maybe a 10 uptick um
but you're still looking at the likely
winners being decided by i don't know
maybe
like 300 000 uh votes or so
which would be something like four
percent of the population maybe
less there are 3.2 million registered
democrats
so let's call it fewer than 30 percent
of registered democrats actually
turned out to vote um and i i will say
that a number of people
expressed to me that they wanted to vote
but uh they weren't registered democrats
and so they could
like they were independents they
couldn't you had to change your
registration back in february they
didn't know that
uh there was one person who said to me
he was working families party
and he thought that that meant that he
could vote in this election but he
couldn't
because you had to be a registered
democrat um so that
so that that was uh to me something
that's a continuation
of the reality of most elections really
in a lot of different environments but
in new york city where
bill de blasio got elected with 280 000
votes
back in 2013 which is you know again
maybe four percent of
of of the city um i think you're going
to wind up with a similar number this
time
um where you have like a fairly narrow
band of voters
that determine the leadership
in the city a significant proportion of
those voters
are very very attached to
city government in some way or you know
like an institution that
works with the city in some way and so
you didn't have the massive increase
that
you'd hope for uh in this context
and this is something that uh certainly
we talked about a lot on the
campaign but this speaks to me to be to
be even bigger where uh we have to make
it in my opinion easier to vote in
elections like this
um for for people of um
of any uh party and certainly uh
if someone does want to vote um we
should make it easier to do so there are
other places that have same day
registration as an example where you can
like show up and
just make that registration happen so we
have what three and a half million
registered voters in new york
um of like probably what four to five
million
people are eligible to vote in the city
of eight million population
you know something around there um and
you only get eight hundred thousand or
so
to actually vote it's crazy how much
people don't give a [ __ ]
about either local politics or mayor
or just anything political in general
but what i learned people should care
because the mayor has a lot of say
a lot of control of how the individual
lives are people in the city
is it that they don't care they don't
know to care they don't
they're distracted by other things the
society of scarcity mindset of scarcity
you talk about where people are too busy
trying to pay rent to care about
voting or community involvement like why
do we not give
a [ __ ] generally speaking um having the
ability to care about politics is
something of a luxury good
truly uh you know like you you you do
have
other basic needs to attend to and then
if you
uh decide to care too because i met so
many awesome candidates around the city
who are running for a city council
or uh comptroller or other positions
um and a lot of them were going to lose
uh you know that but they were still
working their hearts out and they had
volunteers who are working their hearts
out it's really lovely and beautiful
um and you know like the the
uh ability to engage on that level i
think
is something that most people might not
have
because they're busy paying the bills
they're you know like that they're busy
um scrambling to take care of their kids
uh in in particular ways uh i i
you know and i and i think it's
sometimes tough
to care because a lot of times your
candidate doesn't win
um you know it's hard um and so there's
something that
i think um ends up hardening you like
you can become
more jaded um through the process but
what's interesting is that i think most
people sense that
you know like i i have um
like an intention to help people and you
know like have big visions
um and we activated a lot of people
around those visions
nationally uh and then i ran for
uh office in new york city and
translating that vision and optimism to
people
uh was difficult uh
for a number of reasons but i think a
lot of people that had been
in politics for a while um you know i
just become accustomed to the particular
uh
way that things happen i think a lot of
people
uh ignore it because they sense that
there are these things going on
that um that they're not sure that
they'll
be able to influence and if they invest
a lot of time and energy
trying to make it happen then you know
like that their
efforts may not be rewarded so in in a
way
people not caring is is rational which
is kind of sad
you know like that's one of the things
that i'd like to try and change
um like i want to make it rational to
care um
yeah if government doesn't work for you
why would you work to elect people in
in the government right i mean like it's
if you think you're going to get meet
the new boss
same as the old boss then why bother let
me ask you this
we've talked a lot about you talked a
lot about ranked choice voting i know
you're going to write about that in your
your upcoming book
um and we talk about the need for
breaking the duopoly so there's more
parties to engage more types of people
and more people with different
ideologies
you don't feel like you have a false
choice um but that
probably at least my opinion um but i
think i'm right is that it probably
won't
increase the amount of people who care
you know exponentially or enough um
one solution that's been offered and i
don't think we've ever talked about it
is mobile voting um and with like
blockchain technology
and you can make that hyper secure
theoretically
um have you thought about mobile voting
or other solutions to get
more people to vote and care yeah i
i have thought about mobile voting i
have friends who are working on it even
if you enable mobile voting right now
the folks that run these elections are
the political parties
and they i don't believe would actually
adopt mobile voting even though it would
theoretically
dramatically increase turnout which is
one of the problems
uh so i'd love to enable that i want to
make it easier to vote i want more
people to be able to vote
uh i think that is the answer moving
forward
certainly the set of experiences has
made that even clearer to me
um and for those of you who are have
been
following us and the podcast for a while
first thank you
uh really grateful uh you should know
that we
are uh just getting started we have
these
big plans for how we can help solve some
of the problems that i
ran for president on and that's always
the big goal
is like how are we actually going to
further the vision i believe that
running for mayor
would help us further the vision i think
i was right
uh despite the outcome i think i was
right uh
you know we certainly learned a ton made
a lot of
new friends um and
uh have a firmer sense of
just what we need to do but mobile
voting is part of it zach
making it so that people have genuine
choices and that the process isn't as
constrained
is a part of it trying to get more
people to care
and make politics less of like this
insidery thing
um where you have to
uh subscribe to like particular
behaviors and like commitments
uh and whatnot in order to have any kind
of stature or say
um i think uh is a part of it so the the
plan
is still um
uh the plan is still in effect you know
it's like
and one of the reasons i'm grateful to
people who are listening
is that i know over the last number of
weeks uh it's been
kind of a series of non-sequiturs really
but what we're going to get back toward
um
building up the agenda and the movement
um pretty quickly uh you know the and
the the the division is still very clear
um and i'm as excited as ever
uh yeah like that and this this
race has helped uh us
figure things out uh and learn a lot and
you know if you look at it the fact that
i had a chance at crashing the new york
city mayoral race and winning the thing
is
in itself remarkable uh you know and we
we gave it
a really great effort made a lot of
progress
fell short but you know we'll be right
back at it tomorrow
that's true this podcast has been about
building things and building that
community i would like to
um you know i think you and i both could
use a healthy summer break
um you know to keep the podcast you know
well obviously not going anywhere but
also
um a new vision for where we go is where
we'll um
start doing pretty quickly i i can't
wait to share like we you know
we we have a lot of thoughts on paper
um yeah like i mean zach and i spent
much of last year writing
books um in part about what comes next
uh and in my case at least like the the
book is
uh is going to be out a bit later this
year and i can't wait to share it with
people having read your book
i think i told you this when i called
you i said hey um
it's better than your it's your best
book yet and i know what that means
because the second book uh launched up
you know a movement
um eventually led to billions in cash
leave going to
millions of americans and this one is
more important if you will
um especially a couple chapters were
just like yes like preach brother
um so you you should be i we're hyping
this thing up i'm
um but i um hyping it up on purpose
because it's it's
it's that good i'm excited to get your
takes on the news more often which is
what we've been doing in the pal
like what i want us to have from yang
on this podcast at least over the next
couple like the rest of this summer is
andrew there's a lot going on in the
world i want your perception and your
take in your
understanding of it um and i think the
world enjoys that
generally um so i'm excited to do more
of that i hope you guys are listening
you're excited to listen to more of that
we did set
the all-time mark for donors to a new
york city mayoral race
uh in new york city history i mean think
about that for a sec i mean
there's still so much power and
enthusiasm
uh fueling us
uh it's awesome and we we have designs
on where we're gonna go next
uh but for now let's enjoy the summer a
little bit
uh we'll be back with you in in no time
love you new york city
love you america love you yang gang
let's go out and enjoy some summer days
thank you all
see you in a bit zach love you too later
[Music]
brother
[Music]
you